okay salamualikum' I happen to like that
I have three brothers and sisters and
the offense on guys doing well
inshallah on this video this video
before our target is sponsored by hello
sweet company love nest inshallah and
their good works for providing a source
allows sweeties when I'm still waiting
for my practicum shall I'm not a lot of
sweet guy like in a way not like that I
don't eat sweets much poetry so do check
- masha'Allah okay now guys this is a
video about my glasses yes I didn't
describe to wear glasses my vision went
a bit blurry like about last year and
I've got a bigger problem on the right
eye as well it's not that bad home to LA
but I just want to do this video
obviously for you guys to see how I look
with glasses you can give me your
feedback inshallah put a bad for to
expect yeah tell me how it looks in
Charlotte that's later on I'm going to
try it on doable before that is we have
to share remind I can't just do a video
about me wearing glasses yeah okay I'm
at one of those youtubers yeah so
basically it was going to be weird so I
went to the London Eye Hospital they be
some check that some magics like react
to these things in my eye that he was so
irritating anyways away from the results
I've been with busy access so I didn't
get the time to go to Specsavers
yes where my color works and it hooked
me up very much we got mangoes percent
discount still and what I want for cops
let me know so yeah basically what
happened is I've got my glasses and
Allah but the flood won't get onto my
glasses and see how it looks on me which
I've got here they're not diesel by the
way my cousin's giving up one remind I
want to show you that almost is the
blessings of our eyes guys you know if
we think about it how important it is
and I want to share in narration with
you guys here and it is really really
profound a this is this wasn't related
to the first olive oil was telling them
by angel Gabriel yeah the job right yeah
so he comes in from so solemn and says
there was a man who would worship
I was the plan'll title for 500 years
yeah and obviously this man passed away
he died and it's narrated that under
their judgment
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala will tell the
man that by my mercy going to paradise
yet so Alice want Allah will see to him
that by his by his mercy into paradise
so this man obviously he's thinking is
that logically that you know [ __ ]
worship Allah for 500 years I've done so
much etc so he says although I want to
enter paradise but by a good beat yeah
so Alice want Allah says okay if that's
if that's if that's how what you want it
to be okay or I will go with that right
all right no problem
so I miss isn't it an important lesson
for us well insisted because we learn
two things out of this year now then all
songs are okay no problem
let's do that let's get your I won I put
it on the scale and then we'll put the
scale of all the good things that you
have done and worship me for 500 years
he always put just just you I nothing
else no other part of the body just try
so they put the eyes on the scale and
then for all his good deeds I done for
500 years on the scale yeah now what
happens is then the scale these good
deeds are nothing they are nothing
compared to the mercy of Allah giving
you or giving that man his eyesight this
is really profound brothers and sisters
because in his recently look us done so
much know no matter how much we do
bother sisters it will never equate
Allah's mercy in the least in the least
that's why we don't grasp of us want
Allah's mercy Allah Rama is one part of
1991 I'm stakin that one part allows 99
types of mercy of grades of mercy and
only one of them has been given to this
earth which one of them if I'm mistaken
and this man now this has happened so
now our sets of angels okay this is was
the deal yep you wanted to go to
Paradise through your good deeds you
have not you cannot pay me back you can
repay me back for one of your eyesight
so is that angel Satan taking to hell
because now we have to be just but I
want a little more stress so as it's
going is he says all are please please
please all are please forgive me and put
me into Jannah by your mercy this is
really profound guy
because if you think about it so finally
and this is so important our eyesight
well I is so so so it's one of the most
amazing things ever and there is people
out there you can't even see or can
partially see or barely see and this
should give us a reminder and understand
the value of our eyes and how to use
them now this is a reminder to all of us
me first as well to use our eyesight and
whatever part of our body for the right
ways as much as possible now with our
eyes we should protect it from looking
at evil things yeah this goes with both
brothers and sisters lowering the gauge
yes it's hard for brothers and it's a
reminder for myself first
yes what brothers and sisters we should
learn we should learn to abstain to use
what Allah has given us a lot has given
us for a good reason to shut off for
good purposes inshallah this is really
really important and one way you can do
that is one chef gives advisors looking
online and he said anytime you don't
lower your gaze yeah make it off
yourself let's say every time I don't
know my gaze I look some I'm gonna play
to the car yeah make that for yourself
for example yeah now when you do that
because the Shaitaan I think you look
for what yo you're if you're going to do
this every time you look at you got to
like I'm gonna throw you the Shaitaan
tourists often cannot describe me making
him look somewhere is causing more harm
because it's making this game more beat
is gonna play doulica sooner so you can
do that this is one to check that for me
enough what you know that's got the
found you can hear or giving charity say
every time I'm gonna do in charity
because then the Shaitaan I think you
know I'm not gonna make this guy look
because he's going against me because
I'm trying to get to do bad these well
this guys end up will do more cookies so
fight or Shaitaan in that way
insha'Allah now guys it's the time to
see how the glasses look on me are you
guys ready for this I'm quite excited
actually it's not quite emotional as
well and let's hear those here we go
guys are you guys ready yeah I want you
guys to be honest here by the way I got
auntie Claire yeah aunty Glenn please
basically when you drive when I've got
these glasses oh my goodness me wallahi
it just made me realize the blessings of
your eyes like these glasses at
nighttime like I was
for night vision I thought that girl
asked you no man can see everything but
it was amazing that it I can't explain
seed idea I'm mostly probably need to
wear glasses you trust me
when you go to go get go to spec sales
aware go get it checked then you will
see that you see world in a different
place inshaallah going to open it up and
I also got anti-glare which means at
night time you know when there's too
much bright light it cuts out and also
at in the Sun it gets dark so one good
news I'm going move away from the Sun
color I want to see how it looks it
couldn't forget shader because it's
gonna let some glass here so here's all
guys really swing low it was an
emotional background you know tell me
how I look here
[Music]
what do you guys think how do I look
be honest you know I don't want to get
grasses that look like glasses I thought
one of those like will suck shades and
then you know something about the park
etcetera and it you know it turns of
sunglasses well check this out look like
this let's try but you'll still go into
the Sun I'm going to come back here
quickly
okay so I just wanted to go I don't know
why I'm philosophy well suddenly some
sure there is some indigo sleep everyone
yeah can you see Lucky's turn to
sunglasses now here I see but yeah
anyways guys that's about it
do let me know how you think how you
think it looks in Java doesn't matter
but just you know just you know just a
little feedback inshallah yeah as you
can see in Java it's nice instrumental
rock all right is it is it's amazing
while I don't have these glasses on my
vision is just a one thing I don't know
in seven - you guys did you feedback as
well and my vision was a bit blurry it
was a bit very but when I put this on
and when I take off my vision gets more
blurry like like literally so yeah I
don't know just give me feedback Avada
inshallah anything anything else hope
you guys are benefited from this video
may Allah bless you guys inshallah do
share and subscribe inshaallah and do
check out my video at the end and that's
why you guys so next time I saw Molly's
welcome to later care - goodbye and also
yeah if you guys want to do any reaction
videos about congressionals coming out
dilemma which videos - and other than
shallow goodbyes